Exploding moons, exorcist moms
and bowling - this show has it all.
And as the Handler says:
"I do think an explanation of sorts is owing."
You got that damn right.
So in this video, we're gonna take a
look at Netflix's "The Umbrella Academy",
starting with a deep dive into the ending and finishing up with some other cool details you may have missed.
Now, if you want to skip ahead and
take a look at what I'll be covering,
I've left time links in the description.
Just don't jump too far in time,
or you could end up like this.
The final episode begins with a
flashback that simply says "Long Ago",
yet the spaceships and futuristic
atmosphere suggest it's in the future.
That is, unless this isn't Earth:
according to the graphic novels
of which this show is based off,
Reginald Hargreeves is actually an extraterrestrial.
Steve Blackman, the showrunner, said
we'll learn more about Hargreeves's past next season,
so for now we can only speculate.
He says goodbye to his love, whose
death may somehow be involved with
why everyone on this planet is leaving.
It's likely this planet is dying
or facing its own apocalypse.
She gives him her violin, which is later given
to Vanya, which in turn becomes the White Violin.
In the comics, Vanya's villain
code name is "The White Violin",
and it also happens to be the title of the final episode.
Will Vanya still be a villain?
And why did they take her with them?
As Number 5 explains, the
apocalypse will always happen,
and Vanya will always be the cause,
unless they take her with her and fix her.
So, it looks like next season will focus
on helping Vanya harness her power,
fixing her with the hopes of
preventing the apocalypse once and for all.
Back to Reginald, we see him
collect a mysterious jar of floating dust.
Now, you may have missed it, but there's a cut here,
which suggests a bit of time
has passed after he says his goodbyes,
and that she is likely dead here.
The showrunner hasn't disclosed what this is,
but to me, it seems symbolic of letting one's ashes go.
"Probably would have been better with some wind."
Perhaps it is her spirit being set unto the universe,
and how cool would it be if there
were 43 of those floating sprites in there,
the same amount of children who miraculously
were born that fateful day in October of 1989.
Reginald is suddenly in 1928 Earth
with no money to his name.
You can see he's taking a ship on third class.
"Mr. Dawson is joining us from the third class."
If he is indeed from another planet
with more advanced technology,
he likely used this to his advantage on Earth
to become the billionaire that he is.
Creating breakthroughs in biology like Pogo or
technology like robot mom.
It's when he arrives in the new city
that he buys an umbrella shop,
which will later become the Umbrella Academy.
And there's great juxtaposition with the founding of the Academy, followed by Vanya completely destroying it.
Vanya was locked in what's known as an
anechoic chamber, a chamber devoid of any sound.
Since her power relies on harnessing
sound and converting it into energy,
this is the perfect cell for her.
But what Reginald and the others
didn't take into account was
that the anechoic chambers are said to be
so quiet that you can hear your own heartbeat.
Vanya then uses the sound of her heart to completely destroy the iron door that previously held her inside.
She has been taken over by the trauma of her past.
We get a brief glimpse of her
alongside two younger versions of herself,
both of whom harbor extreme
resentment for their father and siblings.
Vanya then experiences flashbacks of
how badly her siblings treated her,
treating her as an outsider
because she wasn't special like them.
"To go on a mission, Vanya, you have to have a power."
It's this resentment that causes her
to completely destroy the Academy,
Pogo, her mother and the world along with her.
It's here we also get a glimpse of
how much further Klaus's powers can go.
For most of the season,
Klaus's powers have been suppressed,
because he can't fully harness them while
under the influence of drugs and narcotics.
Now that he's sobered up, he can
harness the power of his dead brother, Ben,
who saves Diego from a falling piece of debris.
Now, Ben is interesting,
because we never really see how he died.
We do know that it was when he was
younger because of the statue in the gardens,
which means that when Number 5 teleports the
family and we see them as their younger selves,
it's entirely possible that Ben will be
alive and well in the upcoming season.
Even cooler is that Klaus can
allow Ben to manifest himself in reality,
using his tentacle powers to make
quick work of the Commission's henchmen.
Now, we can guess these goons are from
the Commission because of the gas mask,
which we get a brief glimpse of in episode 6.
Now with Vanya on the loose,
the gang decides to hit the lanes,
where they find out Vanya is scheduled to play her
final performance that will unleash the apocalypse
at the Icarus theater.
Icarus being a fitting name, a reference to the Greek myth of Icarus overestimating the extent of his powers,
flying too close to the Sun and dying in the process.
Much like how Vanya's powers
will lead to her own destruction.
You'll also notice the name of
the Chamber Orchestra, St. Pluvium,
"pluvium" Latin for "rainy".
The only thing to stop it?
An umbrella, of course.
Also, these dudes were totally here for Kenny's birthday.
"Maybe they're here for Kenny's birthday!"
A nice little detail that I totally loved is that
the Umbrella Academy are still wearing
their bowling shoes in the final scene.
We also have the matter of Cha-Cha and Hazel.
Hazel decides to kill Cha-Cha on a
freak car crash, so he can be with his love
donut lady Agnes.
But Cha-Cha doesn't die,
instead going on to continue
her mission of protecting Vanya,
because if she can protect Vanya, she'll make sure the apocalypse is successful and get her retirement.
Now, it's also important to know why
this apocalypse is happening in the first place.
The Commission, whose purpose is to make sure the timeline is kept intact, has deemed that this is necessary
But why? Doesn't this mean the end of everything?
But as the Handler says,
"Not everything -
just the end of ... something."
So, we never really get a solid answer on that.
Hazel rushes back to Agnes and
immediately kills the Handler without any words.
Not like the handler would care, anyway, since back in episode 5 when Number 5 has a gun pointed at her,
she says she'll just be replaced by another.
So, next season we can probably
expect a new foe from the Commission.
But Hazel isn't going in without a back-up plan.
He has a briefcase hidden in the
air duct, just like he did in episode 2.
This briefcase will allow him and Agnes to
warp just moments before the apocalypse.
Whether or not they've gone to live happily ever after
or will appear next season is still unknown.
Cha-Cha on the other hand has a final battle with Diego,
and it's fitting it's with him because Diego learned Cha-Cha was the one who pulled the trigger on his love,
Detective Eudora Patch.
But with Cha-Cha's life in his hands,
he decides to spare her,
thinking of Eudora, who he loved because she always saw the good in people, that people can change.
But it's kind of all for naught since
she just dies a minute later, anyway.
You can also see her likely attempting
to call the Commission, who isn't answering.
"Uh, I'm sorry, Michael's not here."
And finally, we have the climactic battle between Vanya and the other members of the Umbrella Academy.
They decide to all attack her at the same time
in the hopes of knocking her out of her trance.
Allison is the only one who's successful
and aims the gun at her head.
But instead of shooting her, she aims off to the side.
Because Vanya's powers are reliant on sound,
the gun blast causes her to release
all her energy upward to the moon,
which consequently crumbles
and rains apocalyptic rock on Earth.
And with nowhere to go, Number 5 suggests he transports them all through time, which actually works.
We see them transform back to children,
suggesting they may go back
to a time where their father is still alive
and finally get some answers from him.
But since we now know Number 5 has this power,
it leaves endless possibilities for
where next season could take us.
And it looks like Cha-Cha, Detective Beeman
and Sergeant Cheddar didn't make it out alive.
But notice how Cheddar here
is reading the same magazine
Allison picked up about her
family earlier on in the season.
And with the timeline potentially being reset, who knows who, what or where next season will take us?
Now, we're gonna jump into some small details
and questions you may have missed.
The Umbrella Academy logo
contains the words "Ut malum pluvia",
which roughly translates
from Latin to "When evil reigns".
You'll see the umbrella in the top left,
which protects from the rain on the right,
symbolized by the lightning.
The bottom right is the mask
representing the Umbrella Academy,
which protects from evil on the left: the skull.
Little is known about Pogo's backstory,
other than he was created by Reginald Hargreeves.
In episode 1, Pogo tells the family
that Reginald made him who he was today,
and he would forever be in his debt.
My guess is that there's a
link between Pogo and the serum
which Hargreeves used to save
Luther after the biological attack.
After all, when Luther offers to give his blood to Allison,
Pogo says Luther can't because he has more
in common with his blood than with humans.
Number 5's story's one of the more interesting.
In defiance of his father, he travelled through time
and accidentally stumbled on the
apocalypse and couldn't get back.
There, he toiled for years until saved by the Handler,
who allowed him to travel via the briefcases
in exchange for completing hits.
This allowed him time to work on his calculations
until he was ready to travel back.
But his calculations were wrong
and he came back as a kid,
but with the knowledge of
the decades he spent in solitude.
One of the more interesting aspects of Number 5 was when he was tasked to kill President John F. Kennedy.
In fact, that's exactly what he was tasked to do
right before he conjured the temporal portal
which brought him back in episode 1.
But did he go through with it?
If you play back the scene,
you'll notice the gunshot sound occurs
after he's made his way through the portal.
So no, in this timeline, he did not.
Luther lives on the moon because his father told him to.
Luther would do anything for his dad,
since he was fiercely loyal.
He was the last one to leave the Umbrella Academy.
His loyalty got him into the condition he's in today,
and he later finds out that his father never
even read the reports he was assigned to deliver.
For Reginald, sending Luther to the moon was the only way to give Luther purpose after his horrific accident.
And yes, that's very messed up.
"That's your takeaway? Oh, wow. Yeah, course it is."
Klaus has a really weird scene, in which he
supposedly talks to God in the form of a young girl.
This actually happens in the comics, but God is
depicted as a grizzled cowboy riding a horse.
Showrunner Steve Blackman stated that even the writers couldn't decide whether or not that's actually God,
So, we're shit out of luck getting an answer for that.
Last but not least, how on earth
did 43 women magically give birth in a day?
Well, this is never explained in the show.
But the comics hint that the 43, collectively, are the modern-day reincarnation of the Messiah.
Whether or not the show will
delve further into this is unknown,
but with 43 born and the show only focusing on 7,
I wouldn't be surprised if more of these children show up in season 2.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
Make sure to Luther smash that "Like" button, and I heard a rumor that if you subscribe with the bell on,
you'll get more great videos.
I also have a Twitter, where you can get in touch
with me and get the latest on what I'm working on.
Until next time remember:
Daddy loves you very much.